Dear Fellow Scholars, this is Two Minute Papers
with Károly Zsolnai-Fehér.
You are going to love this killer paper.
In the classical case of 3D fabrication, we
first create a 3D geometry in our modeling
software on a computer.
Then, after we're done, we send this model
to a 3D printer to create a physical copy
of it.
If we don't like an aspect of the printed
model, we have to go back to the computer
and adjust accordingly.
If there are more fundamental issues, we may
even have to start over.
And get this, with this piece of work, we
can have a low-fidelity wireframe version
printed immediately as we make changes within
the modeling software.
This process we can refer to as real-time
or on-the-fly 3D printing.
In this work, both the hardware design and
the algorithm that runs the printer is described.
This approach has a number of benefits, and
of course, a huge set of challenges.
For instance, we can immediately see the result
of our decisions, and can test whether a new
piece of equipment would correctly fit into
the scene we're designing.
Sometimes, depending on the geometry of the
final object, different jobs need to be reordered
to get a plan that is physically plausible
to print.
In this example, the bottom branch was designed
by the artist first, and the top branch afterwards,
but their order has to be changed, otherwise
the bottom branch would block the way to the
top branch.
The algorithm recognizes these cases and reorders
the printing jobs correctly.
Quite remarkable.
And, an alternative solution for rotating
the object around for better reachability
is also demonstrated.
Because of the fact that the algorithm is
capable of this sort of decisionmaking, we
don't even need to wait for the printer to
finish a given step, and can remain focused
on the modeling process.
Also, the handle of the teapot here collides
with the body - because of the limitations
of wireframe modeling, such cases have to
be detected and omitted.
Connecting patches and adding differently
sized holes to a model are also highly nontrivial
problems that are all addressed in the paper.
And this piece of work is also a testament
to the potential of solutions where hardware
and software is designed with each other in
mind.
I can only imagine how many work hours were
put in this project until the final, working
solution was obtained.
Incredible work indeed.
We really just scratched the surface in this
episode, make sure to go to the video description
and have a look at the paper for more details.
It's definitely worth it.
Also, if you enjoyed this Two Minute Papers
episode, make sure to subscribe to the series
and if you're subscribed, click the bell icon
to never miss an episode.
Thanks for watching and for your generous
support, and I'll see you next time!